c'était magnifique ce que disait le
commentaire que les femmes sont toujours
là pour guérir les blessures pour
recoudre les blessures pour faire
avancer les choses et là ce niveau des
décisionnaires elles sont elles sont
trop rarement là quoi elles sont jamais
là quoi elles sont pas assez pas assez
elles sont toujours dans toutes nos
sociétés et sans parler des sociétés
plus plus lointaines à cause des
religions et des hommes politiques
considérés soit
le racisme fondateur de tous les autres
c'est le racisme antifam quoi et les
religions veulent en faire toujours soit
des soit des vierges soit des
quoi et jamais des jamais les laisser
s'épanouir être une femme qui aime une
femme qui travaille une femme qui vit
une femme qui qui s'exprime je vous
signale au passage que les femmes
veulent pas depuis si longtemps en
France d'abord et puis quand je vois une
femme qui va voter pour un homme moi
pour paraphraser Coluche ça me fait même
sentiment quand je vois un crocodile qui
va spontanément dans une maroquinerie